in this video I want to take you through
this snake-like game that I've built
using javascript and more precisely
JavaScript in functional style or in
functional programming style so with a
focus on purity small functions and
composability
so as you can see here now I'm running
this snake game in the browser and ah
you can see also there that I actually
crashed sorry my camera is in the way so
I can't really see what I'm doing in the
snake game so butBut this is the browser
implementation and because I tried to
put the focus on modularity it was kind
of trivial to make one sort of GUI for
the browser and then another GUI for the
terminal so if we jump over here to this
side you can see if I just look at where
I'm at now I'm in a folder called snake
where I have a few files and what we're
looking at here in the browser is this
web dot HTML file but what I can also do
is I can run this CLI dot J's file
through node and then we can play snake
in the terminal so if we if we run a CLI
through node you can see that we now get
snake but in in sort of terminal mode
let me make this a bit bigger so the XS
represent the snakes the dots are the
grid that's traversable and the o's are
the apples that you need to eat in order
to become longer and the interesting
portion is of course or the interesting
part is of course that this runs on the
same quotation marks' engine like we've
separated the game engine from from the
visuals of the game which is generally
what we should do right we should
separate presentation from the business
logic so my interpretation of most of
these snake tutorials or actually game
tutorials that you find on the interwebs
is that they are focused on just getting
a quick version of up and running
quickly essentially but what I want to
do as I tend to do with all of these
videos is instead talk about design so
I'm by no means saying that this is a
perfectly designed snake game at some
point that just said okay never mind let
me just drop this make this video and
I'll leave it to you guys to hopefully
improve upon this game and make it even
better or rather I should say improve
upon this code and make this code based
even more module
and elegant that would be fantastic so
if you do have comments please do shoot
those in the comments or if you do fork
off from this codebase and make changes
please do post your changes in the
comments that would be really
interesting to read but anyways when we
focus on modularity we can again
trivially achieve this kind of thing
where we have one implementation for the
terminal and one implementation for the
web which of course if we generalize
this notion what we're talking about
here is that you might have a single
core and then multiple different
implementers of that core or users of
that core so that might mean that you
could have let's say a multiplayer
portion of your game or you might expose
your game through an API or you might
make an iOS version and an Android
version and a web version of your game
and so forth and now I'm saying game but
actually we're talking about
applications right so generally what I
usually want to talk about is its design
of programs is how we keep programs
alive over longer periods of time and
how to increase modularity and so in
some sense then this game is just an
example of that but but anyways you
could also just see this as how to build
snake using functional programming in
JavaScript let's get going
so let me cancel out the game here and
let me make this fullscreen
okay so again let me just show you the
files that I have in this folder here so
the main snake implementation is in this
file called snake j/s that's sort of the
core library or the game engine in some
sense and then these three files web dot
CSS web dot HTML and web KS
that's extent essentially that's
essentially the web interface for the
snake game so that's what we were
looking at when we were playing in the
browser those three files and then this
CLI dot JS file that's the node
implementation that's that's what we're
looking at up here I thought that's the
terminal GUI for for through which you
can play the snake game and then finally
this base j/s is some base functions so
essentially when doing functional
programming as I've talked about in
other videos we tend to pass data last
and we tend to have functions that are
curried so we tend to have functions
that are partially appliable
but of course javascript doesn't work
this way so that's why I implemented a
few functions myself such as map and
cetera and of course like if you would
build an extensive game you would
probably use a third-party library such
as for example Ram de Jas or another
library implementing the Fantasyland
specification but for the sake of this
video I really wanted to keep everything
self-contained I don't want to use any
third-party libraries and this is why we
have some code in this base in this base
file then and of course we have this
readme file just because I've put this
up on github and by the way you can find
the link to all of the code in the
description I might have moved it
elsewhere but the link in description
should work let's actually start by
looking at the web and so let's start
with web dot HTML so let me open vein
and then let's open web dot HTML and as
you can see I mean this is clearly just
any old normal HTML file where we we are
loading in the the style sheet here I'm
doing some funky stuff I'll explain that
in a moment but then in the body we have
a canvas setup that's of a size 700 and
of a height or over with 700 and of a
height 500 and then I'm loading these
script tags and maybe it's maybe people
nowadays always load their scripts here
and then make sure that the DOM is load
that in the scripts files I was just
lazy and put them here to ensure that
when I load this web Dutch is the canvas
has definitely loaded but yeah that's a
completely different discussion but
anyways you can see here that I'm
loading in the base library then I'm
loading in snake and then I'm loading in
web dodge is so so clearly I mean this
is because I don't have a build system
setup or I don't have a build process
setup so I mean clearly if you were
building this and actually shipping this
on the web you would you would probably
somehow like minify all of your or all
of your files into a single main
min-jae's file right and you'd only load
that and I would do everything so you
would come construct a single JavaScript
file from all of your other JavaScript
files but now this is just a simple
example so let's not bother with that
right so then we're loading in the base
library and the base library will expose
a bunch of Constable's or it will
essentially define a bunch of functions
that are available on the global scope
and same thing for snake and then web is
the actual machinery of this web of
limitation right
shouldn't say the machinery is the
actual main entry point of this web
application and then let me just quickly
explain this I mean this I do let me
actually let me open up a split here and
open up snake Jas in order to show you
that so snake Taj is because I started
with the the consume with a command-line
implementation actually from the
beginning I was thinking that I only
should do to the command-line
implementation but then I figured
actually it's so easy to make another
web implementation so let me just what
make a web implementation as well I'm a
big fan of trying to keep it as
absolutely simple as possible from the
beginning and this is why I was actually
I started building this snake DOJ's file
and Anna and I started doing it in a
sort of step-by-step fashion where I
implemented one function at a time or
it's like okay this function needs to be
able to do this rights like if we have a
list of snake points and we want to
compute the next next snake point given
a movement in some direction what would
that function look like right then I did
that step by step for all of the
different pieces and then I'm sort of
from the ground up built the the snake
implementation but anyways because I did
this I want to make use of the module
system in node so you can see here in
the end that I say module dot exports
and then I export a bunch of actually
first constants and then three functions
and same thing goes for this base
libraries if we go to this base library
here you can see that this base library
exports a bunch of functions so clearly
module dot exports is not available in
the browser if you're in a similar
scenario with some production code you
should of course look into something
like browser UI or maybe there's
something more modern now but but but
now I mean we just do it we can just
hack it up so so I just simply said that
in the global scope I said that the
require is a function that returns an
empty object right and module is an
empty object and module dot exports is
also sorry so so let me also say I mean
I said require here but I said that the
problem in in this right hand was the
module exports but actually we have so
in snake for example snake actually does
require right so so snake the snake
implementation or the snake game engine
depends on the base functions the
functions in the base library the base
library helper functions so here we make
use of the word require so so the
browser does not have the word require
and the browser
not have the word module nor module
exports and when I say word I'm you know
of course I mean keyword sorry and so
anyways we just say that require is a
function that returns an empty object
module on the other hand is an empty
object and module that exports is a
function that returns an empty object
just just to make them not fail right
they're not doing anything useful
and then I'm relying on the fact that I
know that both base and snake and web
are all defining the functions like this
right here's a function here here are a
few other functions here are a few other
functions and so forth so so if I just
run these at this code in the browser
they will be exposed as global functions
so just a quick and hacky way of getting
this to work but anyways that's the web
right so what it does so you can think
of this as that web is actually the
entry point or web KS is the entry point
and then web law Jas needs to first
require base and then require snake and
this is why they're in this order or
actually I mean to be perfectly frank
rather web needs to require snake and
snake needs to require base that's
actually the more proper way of saying
it so that's that's web HTML let's let's
let's now look at web KS right so so
what does this actually do so we don't
have a ton of lines here right let me
just scroll through this file you can
see here at ya 53 here I'm saying I mean
I added a comment here to say that this
is the main portion I'd say let's
actually start from this main portion so
what web dot J's does so so the
JavaScript that will be run in the
browser when we run the browser version
of the snake game right first we do draw
so these are actually two lines right
sorry I just like I thought it was
pretty good to put them on a single line
so first we do draw one initial draw and
then we say requestanimationframe I
don't actually really know what that is
but but it's something like well the
next time the browser will redraw redraw
using this function please or something
along those lines
so people who develop games tend to use
these so when dotard
requestanimationframe
and then we pass the function step or
the function that's returned by invoking
step with zero and so importantly
usually people do this right they pass a
function but I'm actually invoking the
function step because step when invoked
will
a new function and the reason for that
is to avoid one global or another global
so so step needs to keep track of how
much time has passed since the last step
right because so if I'm not mistaken
like I mean requestanimationframe might
be called different times depending on
the I guess framerate or something like
that of your browser or the frame rate
that you can manage to get on your
browser's like depending on the
performance of your computer your the
the requestanimationframe will be or
rather the function that we pass the
requestanimationframe will be called
with different intervals different time
intervals depending on the performance
of the computer that you're running it
on so in every called two step we need
to check the Delta we need to check the
diff between the current time and the
last time we rendered and that's why I
passed this first variable because here
I'm saying then that or this first zero
because I'm saying that the time since
the last redraw was zero so we're saying
let's instantly redrawn so so here you
can see then that here's the definition
of the step method right so the step
method or the step function I should say
sir it takes a t1 so a time step one our
time stamp I should say it times time
one at a time step two and then it says
okay what's the difference between times
time to and time step one and if that's
greater than a hundred and I don't
really know let's think about this so I
can't really remember but I assume this
is in milliseconds so that would mean a
hundred milliseconds right so a tenth of
a second so every tenth of a second we
enter this portion and all of the other
times we enter this portion and now you
can see how this works right because if
we do enter this portion if there if if
one hundred milliseconds has passed
since the last time we we update it
order the last time we stepped then what
we want to do is we want to say this
state global this global state variable
argot I'll get to this in a moment
equals the next state given the current
state right this is kind of typical
functional program right instead of
doing mutation we're just saying that we
have this global state variable global I
mean you don't you shouldn't have a
global state variable but but like but I
mean in this case it happens to be to be
global but but essentially the point is
containing your state into a single
variable and then passing that state
through a function that produces the
next state right
that given state so instead of saying
well here's my state here are the
actions that I want to do let's change
all of the variables so that it matches
the new state because then some things
are more difficult to reason about
because we have mutation all over the
place instead we say well here's the old
state let me pass you that and then if
you compute what the next state would
look like given that old state well then
I then I know what to do with that right
so that's what we're saying state is
this this state variable and we say next
is a function from snake from the snake
engine and when we pan and when we
passed state to that it will compute the
next state and then we will set this set
the state here this mutable state here
to this new state and then we will do
draw right and draw I haven't even
bothered about trying to make immutable
in any kind of sense because like like
the canvas libraries or they're like the
canvas and api's of browsers are like
there are tons of there's tons of
mutations that would be extremely
painful maybe there is a way to do that
if you have an idea of how to do that
please do something in the comment that
would be or in the comment section that
would be very interesting to read them
out anyways so that's for the if branch
or for the true case right for the
phone's case what happens well in in the
false case or in other words when enough
time hasn't passed 100 milliseconds
hasn't passed since the last time we
updated then we simply do my camera is
in the way I can see but but we simply
do the same thing or we say well we're a
rather i should say we don't compute the
new state and we don't read run
importantly but we do request another
animation frame and to that we tack on
or we throw in a function that's that
says step again from t1 so notice the
difference between this line and this
line right in in this line we have t2
and in this line we have t1 to do and t1
and t2 here is because we want to have
the new point that the current timestamp
as the as the next time step but then we
want to compare against also like as the
as the next time step that we want to
say has a hundred milliseconds passed
from this timestamp right that's what we
want to do when we do redraw but when we
don't redraw we want to compute from the
old timestamp we want to say well you
started at timestamp zero
now 50 has passed 50 is not enough so
keep on keep on waiting but you should
compare against zero and not against 50
because if we if we keep updating this
if we keep changing this to t2 here if I
said t2 here we would never redraw it
maybe in the old case if it's like it's
super laggy or something like that right
but but assuming we have good framerate
and then we would essentially never call
this and then that'd be problematic so
this is why we're saying t1 and of
course I mean maybe this wasn't clear
but what requestanimationframe does is
that it passes a timestamp and that is
this t2 then and I don't actually know I
mean it's not it's not like it's a date
because we start from zero but maybe
it's something like the time since the
the this browser session was initiated
there is something like this I mean this
is the page was van der it I should
maybe say but anyways I mean I have no
idea so they don't take my word for that
but that's that's the update method but
actually let's go up to the top here
because I feel like what I what I didn't
say is this that the state variable that
we talked about is defined here so so
note this comment that says mutable
state so this is so this is the state
variable that contains the state of the
game at all times and it's a global
quotation mark like it's it's shared
across all of these functions in this
file and and what you can do is is that
the functions or actually the functions
don't there are two functions that
change it I should say right there's the
there's the step method that changes it
but there's also this key events thing
like there's this listener for key
events and that thing also changes the
stage right so actually this is let's
look at that at once right or or wait
first let let's begin here in the top so
we can say okay so we say let's state is
equal to the initial state and where
does this initial state function comes
from I mean this is the problem of
working with Lobos it's very difficult
to see where things are actually coming
from since they're not actually sculpt
I'm realizing now maybe I should have
scoped them so that instead of making
these functions all functions in this
file I could have put them inside an
object and that would give us a
namespace here so that we could say
snaked out the initial state because
that that's kind of actually what we're
looking at here like if you would use
require and you would get that for free
but but anyways yeah I should have fixed
that maybe yeah but anyways that's from
the from the snake dot J's files so
snake the J's file
a function called next here all right
then we'll talk about this when we get
to the snake J is filed but but but
suffice to say for now that the next
function takes a state and computes the
next state given that state oh sorry
who's about to talk about initial state
and not about next but that's that next
right that's what next does but if we
look at the initial state that's just a
function it's a I think it's called a
unit function like it's a constant in
some sense so it's a function that takes
no arguments so it's no worry and it
returns an object that is essentially a
state representation but it's the
initial State so the initial state is
essentially always the same so when when
you start a game you need to start from
the initial state so yeah that's the way
we invoke this this state variable now
let's go back down here and let's now
talk about these events so we say
windowed alt so now my camera is really
in the way add add eventlistener key
down so that's the first argument and
then the second argument is this
function that takes a single argument
which is this variable named EU which is
the event and then we can extract the
key variable or the key property from
that event and then we switch case over
over essentially that variable and then
we say okay well we want to be able to
control the snake using WASD the keys
and H hjkl so here's the WASD and here's
hjkl but then we also want to be able to
use the arrow keys right so and
depending on which one of these we press
we want to compute a new state we want
to say that the new state is what the
old state was but plus quotation marks
plus this new direction so these are
constants northwest-southeast these are
constants that i've defined in this
snake dot JS file where we have north
and south and east and west right then
these are essentially just I guess maybe
you could think of them as vectors I'm
not really sure but like they have an x
direction and y direction or a velocity
in these directions right so north means
moving zero x but negative 1y that's the
definition of north we need context in
this game but but anyway sweet so we
want to queue those in and we need to
pass the current state because again
remember the snake game has no clue of
the current state that we have right
it's
it's a actually I should say this it's
pure except for that the snake snake
OJ's final has some randomness right so
we have one function that does some
random stuff and I mean remember
randomness is is impure because it
relies on things such as system date and
etc so given the same input you won't
get the same output but I mean how is
pragmatics here it's just thinking like
there's no point in trying to do
something more complex here in my mind
it makes sense for a function that
computes a random position within a grid
to be within the snake that Jay has
filed and not elsewhere but anyway zero
clearly solutions for that but I'm just
being pragmatic but but essentially so
so then the snake and queue method needs
to be passed the current state we need
to pass the current state as we do here
right and we need to do that because as
we do here because again it's it's
almost pure so it doesn't know what
state we have it doesn't keep track of
its own state and and Q is also defined
here in this snake snake method and
again we'll get to this when we start to
talk about the the snake stuff but
essentially as you can see here it takes
the current state and it takes a move it
asks whether the move is valid and if
the move is valid it does this if it's
not that does that right so if it's not
valid it just returns the same state it
does it does no changes but if it is
valid then it says okay we want to merge
yeah we want to compute the new state
that is the old state plus that this
moves property has changed to the old
moves concatenated with an array
containing only this new move so this
was an extremely complicated way of just
saying append but immutably append the
last move to the list of moves but we
haven't even talked about the state tree
so we'll get to that in more detail but
that's in queue and this is sort of the
basic game right like if you think about
this game first from the from the main
here we draw one initial time and that
sort of does the first drawing but then
we say we'll start stepping from 0 and
then we keep doing this step path ok
step and step and step and step and so
forth and whenever we've it's been a
hundred milliseconds since the last step
we compute the next stage from the old
state and then we redraw and then again
we just keep on looping rotation locks
keep on requesting animation frames so
that's that's sort of update and draw
but then there's also this other
exogenous force that that can enter I'd
like there are also key events so like
when the user types keys we listen to
this and if you happen to type a key
that's that's one of the arrow keys then
we need to compute a new stay so so then
we're also saying well you need to set
the new state to the old state Plus this
new key that's being pressed so that's
that's fairly clear again like the part
that the benefits of mutation or the
benefits of avoiding a mutation is that
whenever you want to change things
usually it's pretty easy to change
things because you don't have to think
about stage so for example I'm not sure
if you noticed but when we played this
game well sir of course how could you've
noticed it's not actually visible and
think about that but the way the game
worked from the beginning was that if
I'm travelling in the direction west as
I'm doing now and I press East right I'm
traveling leftwards but if I press the
opposite direction if I press East right
or conversely if I if I'm traveling to
the right and I press the left key so if
I press the inverse direction or the
opposite direction of the direction I'm
traveling and I would instantly crash
because it's like the snake is moving in
this direction right and it's like it's
it's immediately just going directly
into its own tail right and something
games actually did work this way and was
extremely frustrating and that's right
no this year as well like when I was
playing this it just messed me up all
the time because I kept on crashing what
I wanted to try out the game so I
figured ok let's actually remove that
functionality from from my sneaking and
that's when I added this valid move
portion to NQ so previously NQ used to
only do this right it used to only just
merge in whatever motion you and you
added into the queue of motions or into
the queue of moves but now I said well
actually let's let's avoid this sort of
inverse situation so if you pass the
inverse so that's what valid move does
is it checks whether it's the inverse
and if it's not the inverse yes then
it's melded but if not if it is an
inverse and then we will ignore it and
we'll just pass the old state so will
not queue the move right so it's these
kind of
that we often find ourselves in when we
use immutability like when we realize
okay we'll be cool if the game could do
this or actually this is this is a
tricky thing let's let's not actually
make it do this let's make it do that
instead right and then we try it out and
it actually turns out to be fairly
simple most of the time but anyways okay
so so so this is the hole this is the
the web portion right we have we have
the step function we have the event
listeners we have them you here in the
main let me just put that back on one
line we have this main that that
initiates it and then we haven't talked
about what draw actually does right so
as you can see here is this the comment
says game loop draw right so so this
function draw and it's also pretty
simple like as you can see from the
comments here like I was contemplating
separating this into multiple functions
but given the mutable nature of the
canvas library and like given the fact
that we probably won't reuse this code I
just figured whatever let's just make
this let's actually just make this a
long function that does does all of
these things like one by one so what it
does is that it clears the canvas right
so so CTX here is another global
variable because yeah what to do all
right so that let's actually start from
the top right so the first line says
okay let's let's make a constant
variable called canvas and let's from
the document get the canvas or let's get
the thing that has the ID canvas so if
we look at the HTML thing you can see
that the canvas here actually has an ID
of canvas just to make it simple for
myself right so so I grab that canvas
and then we get the context where that's
that we can draw so so in CT X's is a
context variable then we have these
position Albers here we'll talk about
these in a moment but what we do then is
that we first clear this canvas by
saying okay let's set the fill style to
this like a blackish color i guess and
then we we draw a rectangle over the
hole over the whole width and the height
then the next step is that we draw the
snake right so then we say let's set the
fill style to something which is
greenish and then let's map over the
snake so this is where it sort of gets
interesting right because it's like the
different graphics engines or the
different gooeys or the different sort
of interfaces can have completely
different ways of interacting with
but but so the state exposes that snake
it exposes actually lots of things like
like moves and Apple and and so forth
and so forth but but we're just going to
make use of snake and of Apple so what
we do is just that we map a function
over state of snake and so snake is an
array of positions so it's it or it's
it's a it's an array of points points
being objects that have x and y
coordinates and of course this is not an
actual proper map because I don't care
about the return result so this is
actually more like a foreach that
actually mutates the canvas but map was
a shorter word so whatever any and you
should these iterations of the function
what we do is that we say well using
this fill style of fill a rectangle in
the context from this x position this Y
position over this width and over this
height and now you can see why these x
and y methods and these x and y methods
are just helpers for me so that I'm not
duplicating the same math all over this
place so if you remember what we did was
that we drew rectangles right so notice
how the snake so every point in the
snake or every piece of the snake or
just think of the apples for example
take up sort of one quotation marks
pixel and a pixel meaning like
traversable pixel in this grid maybe I
should say tile actually like it covers
one tile and so what we do then here is
that we compute the position of these
tiles so X 1 here will return the width
of one tile and Y one here overturn the
width of one tile and what happens when
we do this Y of some position is that if
if the y coordinate is zero then we'll
put the little turn to zero right
because if we look at the implementation
of Y here we say take the canvas height
and divide it by the number of rows that
we have in the States so like if the
sorry I forgot to say then we have the
are here as well right so so if R is
zero or being the the y coordinate right
so let's say that the y coordinate is
zero and then we multiply that with the
height of the canvas and let's say that
the height of the canvas is
and then we divide that by let's say 20
which is the the number of rows let's
say so the number of tiles in the
y-direction now this is not necessarily
correct with in regards to this
particular scenario but just
hypothetically it makes sense then you
can see that we get 0 right because
that's a zero at position like that's
the pixel that we actually want to draw
from but if we take 1 we get 5 if we
take 2 and we get 10 and so forth and if
we take 20 we get a hundred because like
that stuff that's the last pixel and
actually 20 doesn't exist if we have 20
it's 19 would be the last one because
its height will also be 5 and then 5
will take it up to 100 but anyway so
those are just two helpers in order to
to not have to duplicate that as you can
see we use these x and y things here as
well so that's the way we draw the snake
and then we do that for the Apple as
well so we say okay here we don't have
to actually iterate we just say fill
rect at this x position at this y
position using this within this height
right and the window height is the same
as the Apple it's as large as a tile
just as all of the pieces of the snake
is is as large as a tile but the
position is based on the on the x
position of the Apple right so so the x
position and the y position so we're
saying compute the Y position from this
coordinate which is defined by state dot
Apple dot Y and then finally we draw the
crash so let's just think about this
unless let's just look about that at
that right like if I if I crash into my
own tail notice how the screen flashes
quickly read write or quickly flashes in
red there you go I did it quickly
flashes in red and how we know that that
has happened is that I decided that well
if we don't have a snake in the game
field that means that either the game is
just started or there was a crash
actually if we just refresh the page you
can see that it blinks red and maybe
this is an unwanted feature and we
should try to solve this but I just
figured whatever let's just not think
about that now
so if there is no snake right so
essentially then we're saying that if
state dots neglect is equal to 0 or so
if we don't have a snake then we should
essentially draw this red rectangle over
the whole screen and so that's the way
we're in the
crash and that's the whole drawing thing
and I mean a moment to pause and reflect
I'd like like the point here is that
this is all graphics right like assuming
that we can use this state structure for
all of the graphics engines assuming
that state trees gives enough
information this can be completely
focused on just the visuals right and it
is not sort of intermingled with all of
the business logic so if we say I
actually just change the color of the
snake it's trivial to find the place
where we can change the color of the
snake or let's make the apples round
it's trivial to find the place where we
make the apples round instead and we
don't have to worry about accidentally
messing up some of the other core
business logic because that's in a
completely different place so we have to
be really silly in order to mess that up
so don't waste that that's the draw
that's the draw function and I think
actually we've covered all of the stuff
here here that write like first we just
grabbed out the canvas we set up this
mutable state that's based on the
initial state we we construct these two
position helpers that will make us
position things in this grid or a visual
grid in the browser then we construct
this draw a function that will take the
mutable state or based on the mutable
state draw a bunch of stuff on the
canvas and then we have this game loop
that whenever it's called checks whether
it has passed enough time in order to
progress to the next state and and
redraw or whether it should just keep on
ticking and then we have these these
listeners that listen for events or
listen for keystrokes and produce new
states based on these keystrokes where
the new states contain the new
keystrokes or contain the directions
that we want to move in and then finally
we have this this main that sort of just
initiates and starts the whole thing up
and of course I mean we didn't actually
need this first this first draw here in
the in the end right like the only
difference if we have that or if we
remove that you can see that there's a
quick flash of 100 milliseconds where we
don't have a board that's essentially
the only difference and that's why I
added that because then immediately we
should get the board actually now that I
think about it's it's almost hardly
visibly like you can see I mean loading
the page probably takes quite some time
anyway so so yeah I mean you might want
to remove that okay but that's the web
portion let's now actually look at the
snake core library
it's probably easier to start with that
and then look at the command line
implementation so let's go to snake
dodge a s so again this is we've glanced
into this file a tiny bit but but not
too much so I think actually there's too
much code here right so let's start from
the top let's just scroll through
quickly firstly to get an idea right
like we have about yes 61 lines of code
and if you have ways of making this
again more elegant and more concise not
concise as in cold golf as and just for
the sake of conciseness but as in
elegance then please do something in the
comments that would be massively
interesting but what we start by doing
is just requiring this base library that
we've defined again as we've talked
about with some helper methods I'm not
sure if we actually ever looked at that
but here's the base library right yeah
we did quickly look at that but we just
define a few a few functions such as for
example map and as constant and as
identity and all of that stuff but let's
forget about that for now right but we
load the functions from the base library
and then we do this and this is kind of
just me hacking again so I apologize for
that but what I wanted to do is so base
for example exposes the function map
right so you have base Dalton map but
whenever you use I don't want to have to
say based off map I just want to be able
to simply say map and refer to based on
map because they are helper functions I
mean in some sense you could argue that
that some of the functions defined in
base here are functions that should be
defined in JavaScript if JavaScript was
actually aiming to be a functional
language like so functions such as Map
Reduce are defined in the preload of
Haskell so they're defined in the base
library of Haskell reduces actually
called fold in Haskell but and not just
that I mean a ton tons of other methods
such as identity and constant and lots
of other things some of them are not
like prop for example like because
Haskell is a statically typed language
and javascript is dynamically typed
language so if we look at the base
library here for example I defined the
helper method prop which essentially
takes a key and then takes an object and
extracts the value under that key from
that object and that's trickier to
define in a statically typed language
actually now that I think I'm thinking
about it actually it's completely
defined upon a statically typed language
is just probably not as use
all right because you're probably using
static typing because it gives you
benefits and when you're starting to use
this sort of key value pair syntax this
dictionary syntax then you are exposing
yourself to runtime errors because you
might end up seen situations where the
key doesn't exist anyways that's
tangental what I wanted to say it's just
that in JavaScript because of the
dynamic nature of JavaScript some of the
functions that we might want to put in
the base library quotation marks it
makes sense to put in the in the base
library but but might not be functions
that we want to put in the base library
in other languages but anyways this is
total sidetracked that's why I'm doing
this right just to expose all of those
functions so I can say K and ID and map
and so forth and not have to say base
dot map and so forth so that's that okay
let's move on then we have these
constants right these constants we've
already talked about we need some way of
talking about the different directions
and maybe you could argue that these
should be functions that or again like
yeah nah Larry functions that take no
arguments and return this but anyways I
just defined them as constants then we
have this point operation and actually
because thinking about this a while like
this is not excellent because if you
could check for deep object equality
right like I think in many of the
JavaScript libraries you can do that and
many of the testing libraries you can
it's actually like object deep equals or
deep equality of two objects is actually
a very useful thing to have in languages
so actually I mean the implementation of
off point equals should essentially just
like if you pass point one and you pass
point two then the implementation should
essentially be 0.1 equals equals 0.2 if
if equality in in JavaScript was based
on the deep structure of an object and
not the the reference to do that thing
in memory or the the pointer to that
thing in memory but anyways I mean and
even if it didn't look like this it
should perhaps be the deep the deep
equality between p1 and p2 and maybe if
we do that in the current fashion it
would look like this right and actually
if we have that then point equals is
essentially equal to deep equals if you
think about that because if I put both
of these at the same time you can see I
mean what we do is simply that we take
one X here one Y here we pass the X here
and we pass the wine here so we're just
applying that function so so then it's
really it's the same thing like we don't
even have to take any arguments we can
make it point free and and that's the
reason I'm complaining about this like
point point the quality is nothing
special like I want to say that the X
point equals the X point at the Y point
equals to my point at the two of the two
things or not the point I mean the X
property of 0.1 equals the X property of
0.2 and the Y property of 0.1 equals the
Y property of point two like that's a
check I want to make but that's just a
check of equality so that's why I'm
saying like that's a bit silly and I was
disappointing but I think it was just
overkill to implement deep equality a
function of deep equality in in the base
library but at least now you know
anyways that's my one so so then we have
a bunch of boolean methods right so so
what I mean here is I mean a bunch of
functions that take some particular or
potential arguments but also also the
the current state and then given the
current state answers questions so the
questions that we want to have answered
is whether the snake will eat upon the
next update given the current state and
whether the snake will crash given the
current state in the next update so if
we have this current state and we have a
list of moves so we have a list of left
right up down etc given the next move
and the current state will the snake
crash that's that's the things that
we're asking here and then this thing is
of course as we talked about before
whether a particular move is valid but
that's before we enter the the move into
the state so I mean maybe we could have
done it in a way we could have just
blindly added moves into the state and
then have a function that computes a
clean state without any invalid
executive move combinations or without
any any sort of inverses in the list of
moves but I but I chose to do it this
way maybe the other way would have been
more elegant but so you pass a move
first and then you pass a state and then
it says yes if this move is okay given
this state so if it's okay to add this
move to this state and the way we do
this is just that we say okay well
there's all this thing about this we do
logical or between this thing
and between this thing right so let's
just let's put these like this just
temporarily so that we can think about
it right so we're doing the same thing
twice we're saying either it either
something holds for for the x-axis or
something holds for the y-axis or for
the Y direction and if either of these
hole then it's a valid move and what
needs to hold is that the X velocity of
the move of the of the last stacked move
of the of the next move that we have
when when we add that to the new move
that we want to add that needs to be
different from zero so so what we're
saying is that if we are moving in X
minus one then if we add one to that
then that would give zero because if
we're moving in this direction and then
we add one so one would be this
direction that would be the polar
opposite of that thing or of that
direction similarly if we're moving one
and we add negative one we get zero
because we're if we're moving in this
direction and we add this direction then
these cancel out and we get zero all
right and that's the scenario that we
don't want where we're crashing into our
own head but we're saying that either
the x axis need to be different or the Y
needs to be different I mean since you
can't since you can't move diagonally
yeah this is in some sense probably
overly complicated because clearly if
the y axis has a value then X will be
zero and if the x axis has a value or if
the x direction has a value then the the
Y will be zero so there's probably a
more simplement implementation that you
could you could look for so let's go
backwards by putting this back on one
line and then let's look at the next
stuff actually before we go any further
let's let's look at this stage right so
initial state let's go here I mean we
said previously that there's a function
called initial state that returns the
initial state that all of the other
states are sort of built from so in the
initial state we have just a few things
right we have some number of columns and
some number of rows and these are just
in order to I mean maybe it's not the
best place to store these because they
won't change or they shouldn't change
over the over the course of the game but
maybe if you would think in terms of
levels and maybe this could actually
change but who knows but then we have
list of moves and the initial and the
initial state we start with east in the
list of moves as you can see right like
when we refresh the game we always start
from the same position here and we
always start by moving east and that's
because the default move is east and we
can't see here because the default snake
is empty but what happens after a crash
is what causes the snake to start at - -
but we'll see that later and then we
start with the default apple actually at
16 - so maybe that should be a random
position but for some reason I chose to
put it there so again you can see that
the apple always starts here so will
always automatically catch the first
apple right by just leaving the snake to
do its thing so that's the initial State
but let's now jump back now you know you
know sort of what that contains and of
course the snake thing right like we
were saying the snake is an array and it
is an array of positions or points right
so things that look like this right then
have an x coordinate and then have a y
coordinate and this is why we're saying
point equal or this is why is a point
because we call these these things that
have Delta X and Delta Y we call these
points so yeah actually so let me jump
down I think it's actually easier just
just to follow along from down here
instead instead of going line by line
because the order wasn't superb so let's
actually just look at the next method
here instead so when we looked at the
web implementation if we go over to web
j/s here you can see we talked about how
we call how we call the next function
here right when we step the game we say
the new state is equal to the old state
ran through this the next function and
the question is what is the next
function do well the next function is
and I make use of this library method
called spec which the library Ram des I
think they call it apply spec or
something like that but I just called it
spec so you can see spec is a fairly
interesting method it has this and has
this slightly tricky come implementation
where it takes an object and then it
takes some value and then it grabs the
keys out of this object and maps over
the keys constructs a a new object from
that key and runs the function that
hides under that key applies that
function
this X that we passed to this value that
we passed and then it reduces over merge
so it simply merges all of these
different different objects that it
produced into a single object is a
pretty complicated way of saying that
essentially what we do here let me just
I mean if I would retype this
implementation we could retype it as
that let's think about it
next is a function that takes a state
and returns a new object where the new
object if I had a spread syntax I could
say is the old state right plus or
actually let's not use this person let's
be explicit so takes take some state and
and and returns a new object where Rose
is equal to state on Rose calls is equal
to State DOT calls moves is equal to
next moves while being passed the state
and snake a snake and next snake being
passed the state and Apple is next Apple
being passed the state so so that's
essentially that's essentially what
we're doing and actually I mean if we
would express this in function syntax as
well these first two just to make it
clear really that why we can use spec
and it's lower implementation is because
this is essentially been just using the
prop method that we talked about before
so if I say prop here pass row yes are
like this right
I passed these props as a string and
then we pass the state as the second
argument and sorry I'm using curried or
functions that allow partial
applications we actually need to invoke
the function like this so that would be
the same thing and now if you look at
that right if you look at that
implementation you can say oh okay well
actually next is a function that takes
some state produces a new object where
the state needs to be passed to all of
the functions rather I should say it
produces a next is a function that takes
some state and produces a new object
where this new object contains a bunch
of keys and to determine the values
under all of these keys we need to
execute a few functions but these
functions they are not no Lurie we need
to pass them
and the argument that we need to pass is
essentially the state like if you line
this up you can see all of them are past
the state so essentially what we did is
just that we we sort of made it point
three we remove this portion not this
how we do this we remove this Boop and
then we say okay all of these need to be
past state okay but that's that's why we
have the speck method so let me say
speck and then we pass state here okay
that's that's also the same thing but
then we're back into the scenario that
we looked at before where it's like well
actually next is now a function that
invokes this this function spec by just
passing in the X that we pass it right
like next is a function that takes an X
and runs another function through that X
or over that X and then we don't even
need to specify the X we can just we
just remove the state here like we
remove the explicit call and then but
then we remove this explicit variable
here and then we just say next is the
running of speck over these functions
and then we pass it some states so I
mean I would argue that this is more
clear but yeah I'm totally empathetic to
if you have a different opinion like as
soon as you start to learn a few of
these really common functional
programming
I wouldn't say parents but like
functions essentially these these common
functions that we tend to use all the
time like constant and ID and map and
reduce and pipe and compose and I would
argue for dynamic languages this method
is this is like super common or this
function spec or apply spec is super
common so we start to recognize these I
actually think this becomes the easier
version to read but there's a whole
discussion about whether point three is
is sensible or not I can shoot some
links in the description if you're
interested in that but anyways let's
move on so so that's that's the next
method and we've already talked about in
queue what in queue does is essentially
that you pass it a state in your pass in
a move and if the move is valid then you
merge the move into the list of of
current moves that you have stacked up
right so so the reason we're stacking
them up by the way is that if
think about it what we can do ah sir let
me collect a few of these just to get a
tail but what we can do is that we can
stack moves like this if I just mash the
buttons sorry now I have a tail now I
can do this okay
so if I just mash the buttons and then I
let go that let's see if this works it's
not crash I just mash the buttons and I
let go you can see that we've stacked a
few moves and the reason we do that is
because of if you've ever played the
game of snake you see like literally in
the Indus anarion right like now I just
want to go right down for example like
immediately right and then immediately
down and I think I could just queue down
after right so I just press right down
and then I've cued it so like if we
didn't do something like this maybe we
wouldn't be able to get both of them in
action now that I think I'm gonna that
would probably work still I don't know
maybe I'm some opinion opinion about
that I mean what wouldn't work is this
sort of stacking but then again this
stacking isn't necessarily super useful
I assume but anyways let's get back to
the code that was the original intention
of why I did it as a list so yeah not
not thank you so we've talked about in
queue we've talked about next we've
talked about initial state and what we I
guess what we should do now is just talk
about well first let's talk about these
so the next state is computers from the
old stage right and rows when we do prop
rows and prop calls as we looked at in
the other implementation that just
equates to the same value like we just
say this value is whatever the old value
was but however next moves let's
actually look in next moves right so the
search for cons next moves right and
what this does is that it says okay it
takes some state and an remembers what
it doesn't engine is that it takes the
whole state but the intention is that it
should produce only the list of moves
right so it takes the whole and it
produces the part so we take the state
and when we say ok state that moves that
length is greater than 1 so so we say if
we have more moves than 1 then we should
drop the first move all right so so drop
first is a function that I've defined
here in the base drop first which is I
mean it's trivial we just call a slice
on an Iranian slice and then pass one
but I just did this to make it more
readable all right because now we
actually like very easily see what it
does so we said drop the first from
state moves or if the if the length of
the the moves list is not greater than
zero right so so if we have only a
single move left then it will simply be
stated moves so what this means is that
if we have more than one move we will
drop the the first move because we've
used it like in the next in the next
state we won't have this this we won't
have the first move left because we've
now used it but if we have only a single
move and we shouldn't do that because we
want to keep repeating that move right
that that's how we're achieving this
effect where it just keeps moving right
I mean I'm not touching anything it just
keeps it just keeps moving to the right
so that's the because we keep that in
and of course let me just quickly
mention again that you can using
fractional programming you can make a
lot of things point three point one and
point two I've also kind of makes this
this sort of object-oriented dolt syntax
with this function syntax where you
truly like truly have a function and
then pass the data and I have a bit
disappointed about myself for doing that
but anyways I mean I just feel that stay
pragmatic but probably like here you we
should do something like this like
length of stated moves because this this
dot syntax is fine because this is
purely data but then length is a
function on that but but this is sort of
give and take I mean I don't think we're
going to be able to get away from this
anytime soon in JavaScript because like
maybe my terminology is a bit shaky here
but if you've tried Haskell for example
like you have a dog polymorphism and you
have parametric polymorphism and ad hoc
polymorphism is kind of like
polymorphism in object-oriented
programming and so so the so the thing
in Haskell is that you can actually
define a length function that takes some
data and then does different things
depending on the type of that data
that's a bit tricky in in a language
such as JavaScript because we don't have
ad hoc polymorphism in that way the way
we achieve a dog polymorphism is through
object-oriented polymorphism is is by
saying that length is a function that
exists on an object and in in a
dynamically typed language such as
JavaScript we say well everything is a
type right like if it quacks it's it's
it's a duck so everything that responds
to length is length double but which
implementation of length you get depends
on which object you call the method
length on so I mean it's a it's a
give-and-take like we probably have to
mix these two types of syntax before we
have facilities for ad hoc polymorphism
that looks a bit more like something
like Haskell in JavaScript which
probably we maybe won't because maybe
I'm not realizing how difficult that
would be to implement in a dynamic
language but anyways now we're way out
of the zone so so so let's get back into
this game are you but I just wanted to
mention that that I'm completely aware
that that's it's not it's not superb
anyways how do we compute the next
position of the Apple well if this is
what we get to this we'll eat that we
talked about right like if the snake
will eat the Apple given the current
state then we need to spawn a new
position and that's when we're using
this or in the post that we talked about
that's that's the that is the function
in this snake library that is impure or
actually I mean then next Apple becomes
impure because it's making use of an
impure function block matter so if the
snake given the current state will eat
the apple
then we need to spawn a new position for
the apple based on the current state if
it's not if it's not if the snake is not
going to eat the apple then the apple
will maintain in the maintain its
position that the new position for the
apple will be the same so let's actually
for the fun of it I mean let's let's
actually do the same thing in both of
these cases right like we have the cases
where it really isn't we have the case
where it won't eat so let's change the
won't eat case two also spawning a new
apple at a random position and then if
we refresh this and run this again you
can see that it's absolute and total
madness right because now we have the
Apple the sort of respawning at new
locations regardless of whether we're
eating the Apple or not so actually I
mean I don't know the probabilities here
but it's probably I have no idea whether
it's higher or lower but girls like it
this is a very tricky game to play so
this is surely not what we want then and
and then also for the fun of it let's
try the other thing like let's say
instead of when we eat an apple that's
spawning it's at around a position
that's just spawn it at the same
position let's say that the the new
position of the Apple
the same as the old position at the
Apple regardless of whether we hate it
or not then we can see that what happens
is that we don't spot a new Apple right
the game works fine but we can just like
hands off and then just leave it like
this because we're just going to eat all
the apples in that we crash and actually
it's probably still tricky again because
the snake will take up all the screen
and then it's gonna be tricky to eat the
apple but anyways I mean it would
clearly what we wants isn't random
positions we want is this like we spawn
a new position when we eat the apple and
again there's like this is some of these
things are really easy to to think about
when you have immutability unlike I
would imagine that going back and forth
between these two changes would be more
difficult if you had it would
potentially be more difficult if you
have mutable state depending on how you
had structure your code clearly next
thing let's move to the next head right
so next head well let's think about it
this way we have next snake and we have
next head so maybe these should be in
the other direction right so so and I
think next snake was called in the next
method here right so yeah so we're
saying snake is equal to next snake so
if we go back to next snake here and
next snake makes use of next heads so
let's actually talk about next snake
first so let's first think about this
snake right like look like look at this
like let's actually grab one more Apple
here so now so now we're a snake of
three dots right if you look at it now
we're four but so so the snake is a list
of positions and now it's a list with
four elements that each have positions
and I think if I'm not mistaken you will
have to see either the first element or
the last element in the list is the head
of the snake so what we do is that we
just when we need to move the snake we
remove one element in the end and then
we add one element in the beginning and
when we eat right think about it look at
what happens when we eat then we the
snake is prolonged so what happens is
that we add one in the front but we
don't remove one in the end or I
shouldn't say we add one in the front
what I mean is we do compute the next
position of the head but we don't remove
from the tail right so we have the snake
here and then we're saying okay if you
if you're not eating we should just take
the snake and move it here but if you're
eating then we should take the head and
move it here but this tail should be
fixed we should not remove anything from
the end because it's this removing that
makes it gives the appearance of it
moving right because it's actually that
we we remove this thing and then it's
easier maybe if you just think about one
dollar as like if you have one one dot
like one one one snake head then what
happens when we're not eating is that
we're just saying okay remove this poop
and make another one here and that gives
the appearance of moving right soup and
then soup and so forth but if we're
eating we're saying create the new one
right you have one here create the new
one soup but don't remove this one right
so so we give the appearance of
prolongation and not off of extension
and not of moving of course it's moving
as well but but anyways that's the way
that we structured that by the way I
mean I tried this in multiple different
approaches that I was a true I mean it's
an interesting game because you can also
approach it by building up a grid and
then sort of making operations on that
grid so like you have a 2x2 array like a
matrix but anyways maybe if you if you
try out the solution along those lines
maybe I can shoot something in the
comments that would be interesting to
look at so to compute the next snake
what do we do well what we do is that we
have two ifs we have two nested ifs we
say okay if the snake will crash right
given the current state given the
current direction give it the current
world if in the next state that we are
now computing will the snake crash or
not like if it will crash then the next
snake is going to be an empty rate then
we're going back to this sort of initial
State thing we're saying let's go back
the snake is an empty array however if
the snake won't crash we do any of these
things and if it won't crash we're
asking this well is it so that the snake
is eating because if it's eating then
what we want to do is just that we want
to add the next head we want to compute
the position of the next head like we
did here with your hands right like we
have one we have this we have a snake
here and we want to add the snake here
we want to move it here right and if
it's eating we just want to compute this
new position and then we want to concat
that into the current or with the
current snake however if it's not eating
then we need to move it or we need to
give the appearance of moving that means
we can't just compute the new position
but we also need to drop the last
positions we need to remove something
from the end and let's just think about
whether it sits in the head or not so
what we're doing is that we're saying
the head is an array and then we conk at
that with the old snake yeah so what
we're doing is that we're adding into
the beginning right so we're not it's
not that we're pushing in positions into
the end of the snake but it's more like
we're adding at index 0 and then we're
shifting all of the other ones backwards
so I am and at all thought about
performance and efficiency but I mean
clearly if there are probably multiple
ways you could improve this code but so
that's what happens when we were when
the snake is eating we are adding a new
head but we're not removing the tail and
if it's not eating we're adding a new
head and we are removing the tail so
actually I mean if we if we remove this
drop last just to try this out right
then we're saying it's going to get
longer all the time so if we run this
now you can see just like it's it's
never ending like it doesn't matter if
we eat or not the snake is just growing
and growing in the ABS tricky for me to
help but as you can see right like the
snake just keeps on growing and growing
and growing again like a trivial thing
to change but we go back to actually
dropping the last and of course if we
did drop last here as well just to be
exhausted let's try that as well now
would mean that even if we are
collecting apples nothing happens like
the snake isn't actually prolonged so of
course what we want is that like this ok
that's the next snake but then ok as we
were saying next next next snake makes
use of next head so the question is how
do we compute the next position and
that's actually pretty interesting
I said let's look in the next head so
again next head the structure is that it
takes a state and it produces a single
position or it's a so thing about it I
mean next snake takes a state and
produces a list of snake positions next
head takes the full state and produces a
sin
position that represents the head of the
snake and what it does is that it too
has to ask an if question and the if
question that it asks is that do we
currently have a snake or not right like
if the length is zero like if you look
here right as we talked about in in next
snake of course when we crash we
completely wipe out the snake so that we
don't have a snake so when we compute
the next hand it might be that we're
trying to compute the next head from
from no snake at all so this is why
we're asking is the length zero because
if it is zero then this we want it's
like the default start position maybe I
should have had that as a comment or
something like that
I actually if you look at it if we
refresh here you can see that this
supposedly is two two
actually let's think about that means so
x3 and y3 if you start from one so this
is why I mean maybe one would assume
that it's here but actually this is one
one because this is zero zero so here
it's zero zero 1 1 and then 2 2 so so
yeah we started to - all the time and
that's essentially because when the
length of the snake is 0 then we spawn
at - 2 and again I mean we could do or
indeed let's say aren't be pulse given
the stay yeah that should work as well
then we are starting at random positions
we're always starting going east but now
we're spawning it at random positions
we're spawning the snake at random
positions but I figured this this makes
sense I mean it's kind of nice to start
from from - - and that also it's obvious
that you've crashed so that's what
happens if this thing is zero like if
it's the initial case but if we do have
a snake like if the length of the snake
is currently longer than zero what do we
do well this I found pretty good we
create a new position that has an X and
then I have that that has a why of
course and what we do is that we take
the I mean think about how these two
look very much the same right like x and
y is essentially the same thing but what
we do is that we say the x position is
the current x position of the snake of
the of the current head of the snake
right what's in the 0th position plus
the ex of this move that we've stacked
the next move that we
want to grab so the the move that is
pending the move that it that were
supposed to execute now and remember
like the moves that we can have are are
any of these north south east west east
well west
so if we have east stacks right as in
the default case then then X will be one
so what we're saying here is that we're
saying stay thought is snake so we're
taking taking the state position is a
snake position and supposedly if we
start at two and as we've defined as
that as the sort of default start
position here so if we start at at two
and then we say plums and we add one
because East is one so the default
direction is 1 then we get three right
because the current head is at two - or
if we only think about the x position
the current head is at at x2 and then if
we add one we end up in x3 right and
that's actually that the next head now
the question that and of course maybe
what we should mention is that this of
course works for negative as well so if
you have if the position is two and you
add negative one then you get one
because you're moving in the other
direction and the reason and that we
have this modest thing is that we're
making use of the modulus operator so
actually I mean in the best of worlds I
would never had to write that I should
have been able to write something like
let's think about this so so this so the
same calculation mod state dog calls
that's the way I wanted to use like we
want to use the the mod operator but
apparently the modulus operator in
JavaScript behaves differently then than
I had expected in regards to negative
numbers but think about it the reason we
use modulus here is that because we want
to have this wrapping effect right like
notice how when we go out of the right
end of the screen like it's a torus
right we go out on the right end of the
screen and we show up on the left hand
and similarly if we go out on the left
and we show up on the right and and and
that modulus operator is actually
everything that's needed to implement
that because what we're saying is that
if the grid let's say that the grid is
12 right let's think of a clock so if
i'm not sure if i can do mod here
actually
so if I do 10 yeah I can't okay so let's
do it in Google so so if we do 10 modulo
12 for example we get 10 because let me
be more clear so if 12 is the width of
the grid and we're talking about the x
position would say so the number of
columns that we have to work with is 12
and that means that 0 is an okay
position 11 is an okay position 12 is
not an okay position so if we do 0 12
modulo 12 that means that it's the 0th
position so what I mean is that 12 is
the size of the grid and and 0 is the
position that we want to position the
next head in if we don't think about
this wrapping around right like then you
could say position 316 right like even
if you have a grid of 12 actually I mean
we could do that that's that's the point
of modulo so if we do 316 modulo 12 that
means that if you try to move to
position 316 you should actually be at
position 4 because you've wrapped around
you've looped around and multiple
multiple times but if we just think
about the edge cases right like the 0
yields 0 so that means the zeroth
positions that means we're not changing
0 and if you do 12
you also get 0 because 12 modulo 12 like
12 divided by 12 gives a remainder of 0
so that also puts you back in in
position 0 which makes sense because
we're saying it's 0 indexed right so so
because we have the 0 index the max
index is 11 so when we try to go to 12
we should wrap around back to back to 0
so maybe I'm not making a superb job of
explaining this but but every number
then between 0 and 11 inclusive will be
the number that we pass so if we pass 2
we get 2 if we pass 3 we get 3 if we
pass 4 we get 4 and so forth but if we
pass higher numbers which happens when
we are at position 11 and we pass 1
right so or we add 1 right so this is
more like
that we have we are at position 11 we
pass one and then we do modulo 12 of
that so that gives us 12 that we do
modulo 12 on and that gives us zero that
makes us wrap around back and let's jump
into node quickly and look at this so
actually I should have done this in
notes from the beginning so so 10 modulo
12 gives us 10 right and but 12 modulo
12 gives us 0 which wraps us around back
similarly 13 and gives us 1 but this is
a case where that we were never seen
however what I would want is that
negative 1 should also wrap so negative
1 should put us in the other end of the
12 and that's the way I was expecting
that that modular was behaving so let's
see can we actually can we require the
base library from here so let's try to
require base oh sorry
base equals required oh sorry because I
now I declared it twice but messed up so
let's restart jump back into node so
let's require the the base library Wow
sorry I'm such a confused person so
let's jump into node and let's say Const
base is equal to require from the
current directory the file called base
that should be specific in sage is right
and that works then we have the base
library and base I mean the base are
aware that we've defined in this project
and base has the function mauled right
so this mod mod however works
differently I mean it works the same if
you pass 10 and 12 again then you get no
sorry it's the common case art for other
reasons I did it in the other order so
here I pass so this if I pass it this
way I mean 10 module 12 then we get 10
and if I pass 12 we wrapped around 0
similarly for 13 but again we never end
up in that scenario but now if I pass
negative 1 will wrap around in the other
direction and end up
eleven and modular two and so forth so
so yeah and that's a different
implementation of of modulo and I think
I left a comment here yeah I left a
comment here to link that you can check
out if you're interested in the source I
think that came from a stack overflow
post or something like that so anyways
the house
what are these moments where you go like
ah excellent like it's it's awesome when
when math can make problems that seem a
bit tricky to solve in programming but
math makes them trivial those are the
good days right but anyways so that's
why we do modulo here so what we're
saying is that this is the raw quotation
marks the raw new position and then we
say take that position and do modulo of
the the size of the rows or the coals
depending on which one we're working
with so that we wrap around but yeah
that's that's next head and so next
snake is based on the on that next head
essentially and yet the randomness here
we've talked about the initial state
we've talked about next we've talked
about and Q we've talked about oh my god
and we actually talked about everything
now so yeah I think we've talked about
everything and that sort of covers it in
getting to the point where where the
snake game is operating something like
this because we also looked at the the
web HTML and J's file and of course I
mean I also have this web dot CSS file
with just some basic styling in order to
make this look a bit prettier I mean if
we remove I'm not even sure like if I
remove this stuff it looks like this
right I've actually zoomed in so this is
the this is what we actually draw on the
canvas but this is just some days
exciting that I added in order to make
it look like this but yeah that's it
before we wrap this up let's actually
also look at the CLI so the command-line
interface so I'm opening up CLI ljs
right and let me just map a keystroke
here in them to run node on CLI dot j s
or to run CLI the J's through node so if
I just hit that we're running this and
again you can see this works fine and
actually I mean this is a pretty short
term imitation as well so the game loop
is a bit different here we still do this
sort of showing and stepping but what I
do is I
set an interval yes so what we do is we
make use of set interval right which is
this function in JavaScript that calls a
function with a regular interval it's
also expressed in in milliseconds but
here actually I run it every 80
milliseconds so yeah for some old reason
I chose a different interval for the
terminal application maybe we should
change this to 100 and in order to sort
of make it have the same speed but
nevermind I mean that we can trivially
change but essentially what this set
interval does is that it does these two
things right if we pass a function to
set interval that first calls step and
then calls show and actually I mean now
that I think about it what we could have
done is we could have said pipe step
step and then show like so over ad and
that should be the same that should be
the same thing right and actually that
didn't work and I think it has something
to do with like the console.log here or
something like that so like the context
disappears but never mind let's not
think about that now and either way I
mean piping here is not necessarily a
sensible thing to do because a step and
show are are mutating functions or there
are functions that like I mean compose
and pipe usually use when we actually
want to pipe or compose functions like
because we're actually passing data
through now we're just doing saying do
this thing and then do that thing so
they can never mind but I know it's so
set interval what it does is that it
calls step and then it calls show and it
does that every 18 milliseconds and what
show does that let's serve the show and
so both of these both showing step are
functions that don't take any arguments
and show what it does is that it console
logs this strange character which works
as a clearing right like if you think
about it actually if I if I remove this
I think that would be the most simple
way of describing this like if we remove
this and then redraw you can see that
the game works right but if I if I
scroll out you can see we have multiple
versions of the game where the the lower
one this one here in the bottom this one
is is the active one because that's the
freshest one we are the other ones are
histories and actually we are we are
printing and printing and printing and
so it's not like it looks static but
it's not actually static I mean it's
like I'm moving like these old animated
movies like where you draw where you
pull past the strip of multiple images
and that's actually exactly what happens
now like this is strip of multiple
images anyway service that's stopped
thinking about that now it's but it's
pretty interesting but if we add that
character we keep clearing the screen
all the time so that we're just it's
like clearing the canvas so that's
that's the first part part of show like
we clear and then what we do is that is
that we have these these functions on
the object matrix right so so here you
can see we have a comment that says
matrix operations and I'm following that
there's a constant called matrix which
is sort of a module with a bunch of
functions that operates on matrices and
actually I mean I used in board matrix
here indicative Li like it's not
actually truly a matrix but what we have
is that we have an array of an array
like we have a two-dimensional array
where the first I think first I do rows
and then I do columns or maybe the other
way around so anyway the the things
under matrix under the matrix module are
then things that operate on things on
this type of structure and so what we do
is essentially then that we say okay
matrix dot to string of mate matrix not
from state given the current state so
here we probably could actually use pipe
in a sensible manner so what we're doing
is that we're saying yeah pipe and
matrix matrix from state and then matrix
to string and we're piping that through
the state L so this is probably the
reason why I didn't do this because the
line turned out to be longer like if you
compare the two lines this is actually
longer but that should work fine as well
and like if we run that all right that
doesn't work fine
oh sorry my bad this is probably why the
other thing didn't work as well we're
not using array syntax I should pipe
like that yeah sorry so that's probably
why the other thing didn't work as well
not
we didn't have anything to do with
console.log but anyways so yeah we could
use a pipe there instead but has just
said I mean even even if I remove that
sort of array here you can see that this
line is longer and I just figured
nevermind let's just do this
but anyways I've both these things are
equivalent but yeah maybe maybe this one
is more clear so maybe let's keep that
one I guess I didn't because of the
length of the lines like you can see
we're at 88 everywhere at : 88 but
anyways let's keep it like that for now
so that's show so what it does is
essentially it clears the screen it says
construct a matrix from the current
state remember the state is the same
kind of state that we used in the web
GUI right like that's what we're saying
like we use the same state tree but we
do different things based on this state
tree and thus we can show our
command-line interface and we can look
and can show a web interface so from
this current state we we produce a
matrix and then we take that matrix and
we pass it to two strings so what we do
is that we produce the matrix and then
immediately we turn that matrix into a
string so actually I mean maybe you
could argue that I've made it
unnecessarily complicated in some way
and maybe we should find a way which is
more similar to the web approach or we
sort of just immediately do what we our
display what we want to display but to
me this seemed like the easiest approach
like having this intermediate data
structure that's this matrix like thing
because I mean if you think about it we
print this pretty much as a matrix right
like this is this has a number of rows
and it has a number of columns and
actually if we look at two string here
in the matrix module you can see that
this is where it becomes obvious that
it's it's fairly trivial because to
string takes I wrote X's X's here
because like usually in functional
programming you can you will see people
to say like XS or SS or something like
that to indicate that you have an array
of something so you have an array of XS
here but I I tend to write X's X's I'm
not sure if that's conventional I hope
that's conventional because it seems
sensible to indicate that it's an array
of an array of X X's so and that's why I
say X's X's here on the outside and then
X's here on the inside so the way this
works is that we map over the the outer
array and then for every inner area
we join up all of the values with a
space if you think about it you can see
here that there's a space in between
there's a space in between all of the
different dots like if we didn't have
that space probably this wall yeah and
this actually does work right this
doesn't look very nice also because
columns are a lot narrower than the rows
so so we need that extra space in order
to sort of make it look a bit more nice
so we join it up with space and then we
join up each of these rows with a
backslash or backslash n which is
actually a line break so that we can
print it as a single string that that
sort of looks like a grid and actually I
just realized I used to have a point
free or not a point free version of this
but rather a version that's more similar
to the make function here where instead
of actually calling map on the axis of
X's we say map and pass the axis of XS
because I guess that could be more
elegant than this but anyways there are
multiple ways you can rewrite this
function and some of them are probably a
lot more elegant and the way I've
written it now but anyways that's the
two string function and of course if we
think about this method again like what
we were saying is that we first do from
state and then we do to string so we
start with this from state and then we
do to strange so from state what that
does is that it creates one of these XS
of XS it creates one of these grids or
one of these matrices containing the
appropriate values and how we do that is
essentially by piping right we say well
we need to pass this state so we take
the state as an argument and then we
pipe it through a few functions but the
first function makes the matrix the
second function adds the snake to the
matrix this third function has the Apple
and the fourth function adds a crash if
there is supposed to be any crash so
again these are sort of immutable
methods in order to just to keep my head
straight in this so matrix don't make we
can see up here I think matrix does make
here I called it table and not state
because a table is anything that has
holes and rows but I mean actually what
we will pass is we will actually pass
the state but since we only care about
their Colton the rows I figured I'd call
it
here and what we what make does is
essentially that we use this helper
function rep right so if we look at the
base library cones wrap here we have the
implementation of rep and what rep does
is that it takes a constant and then it
takes an N and then it Maps this
constant using the function K which is
the Const function over the range from
zero to n so this sounds a bit bonkers
but what what this actually means is
that if if you have actually let's let's
jump in to know then let's look at this
so a Const base is require right and
then we have the base library and then
we can say base Dalt rep and if i say a
and then i'll pass 10 you can see that
we get 10 a's if i get it past 3 you
will get 3 a's right then if i instead
of a if I have one here I was
essentially get an array with this thing
repeated the number of times as the
second argument that were passing and
rep was implemented in terms of range
and what range does is just that let's
see if I can remember the syntax if we
do this right then we get a range from
10 to 20 we can array of all the
elements of 10 to 20 so we were doing is
that we were mapping over that range in
order to have an array of multiple
elements and what we were mapping is
that we were mapping the function K of
the the constant that we were passing so
when we did based on rep a 10 I here up
in the beginning for example then our
constant is a so if I say K of a then I
have oh sorry base K then I have a
function that accepts an argument but it
doesn't care about which argument it
it's passed regardless of what argument
is passed it's going to respond with a
and that's how we can when we map so so
actually let's let's do that manually
like if I have that range from 10 to 20
and then I map over that and if I map K
of a we will replace observe base KN
based at K we will replace all of the
values in the rear
with a and that is essentially the way
that a rep works and yeah I guess range
and K as well and map but anyways so
that's why we do rep rep here so it's
pretty interesting I mean what we do is
we repeat the repetition of period or
this the string period over the number
of columns that we have in this table we
do that for every row that we have in
this table so that's a pretty concise
implementation of making a a
two-dimensional array of filled with
dots right so that's the first thing we
do we make the matrix based on the state
we make the matrix from the state but
then here we have these three functions
that we want to use to add additional
things to this to this matrix we want to
change particular we want to adjust
particular cells in this matrix and note
how we're passing state to these because
essentially this one or only requires
the state to be passed once but these
actually require the state to be passed
twice so we'll invoke them like this so
ad snake is a method that can be defined
only when we know what the state is and
this I mean I was struggling a bit with
this I think this didn't turn out super
nice so if you have any suggestions of
how to rewrite this properly super
interesting if you want to post anything
about that I was toying with the idea of
probably using the S Combinator or
converge or something along these lines
but probably we could find out more
sensible ways of expressing this but
anyways what we do essentially is so add
snake what it does is that when given
some state it will it will produce a
function that's essentially a pipeline
where we spread the mapping of setting X
or rather I should say spread the result
of mapping the value x over the snake so
essentially this is the thing about it I
mean this looks a bit hairy but like
actually it's not a stranger I mean so
the the thing about it like the snake in
a state it is an array it's an array of
position so what we do is that we map
the function of setting X and setting X
in the matrix takes a particular
precision and so by mapping that we get
a list of function
that we then spread over this piping's
we spread it into arguments so we make a
function that when passed a state will
run that state or sorry not when passed
the state when passed a matrix will pass
will run that matrix through a bunch of
matrix not set transformations that set
sets x at that particular position and
if you look at set I mean set is also
fairly straightforward what it does is
that it takes a value and then it takes
a position and what it does then is so
the position is then a point right maybe
I should have set points or something
that has an x and y and it called adjust
on the Y or adjust at the Y position but
then passes the adjustment of the x
position of the constant of the values
so what we do I mean actually I mean if
we if we express this in a less strange
manner actually what this is is that
we're saying why I mean if we would do
this in a mutating fashion what it does
is that it takes another argument
because it's point free right so it
takes it also takes the matrix and what
we do is that we say the matrix of the
position Y and then position X is equal
to the value and then we return the
matrix like and then we return the
matrix so that's essentially what what
the set method what the set function
does but but now we're mutating and so
now we're trying to do that without
mutating and when doing that we also got
rid of the matrix variable here and and
of course adjust is a function that we
defined here in in our base based helper
library but of course it's also
available in a lot of different
libraries and what adjust does is simply
that it takes an N which is an index it
takes a function and then it takes some
kind of collection some X's and what it
does is that it changes it runs the
function at the index n of the XS right
so so it's a way of if we go back here
right like we say list index equals
value or more specifically if we say
function over if we run a function over
the
you add that index right that's what
what this version of adjust does and
then and then we pass kay here because
we're not actually interested in running
a function over the value we don't care
about the old value we just want to
replace it with a new value so that's
kind of a general version of adjust and
yes so this we do in order to - so
essentially what set does is that when
given a value when given a position and
when given a matrix it produces a new
matrix that looks like the old matrix
but where the value at the position has
been updated to the new value and that's
essentially what we do with set right
and so that's why we use it in in add
snake and we also use it in add Apple
and actually not add crash because here
we did a more simple implementation I
guess but yeah that's how we use it in
add snake the way we use it in add Apple
is much more simple much more simple
then we just simply say matrix that's
set and we set to an all at the position
of the Apple right so state of Apple
contains a position and we're just
saying matrix that's set at that
particular position right so I mean this
we could change to an A and then if we
run you can see that we now have a x'
instead of always that represent the
Apple so that's the Apple and then the
crash is very simple here we just say
that okay if the snake length is zero in
other words if we don't have a snake if
we've crashed or if we just started the
game then we map the mapping of the
constant
- so over this grid think about it the
grid is a list of lists so over every
column or row depending on which word we
structured it anything maybe its row so
over every row we map but we map the
function that is the mapping of every
column and over that we map the function
K which is constant that returns
regardless of what it gets returns
whatever we passed it and what we passed
it in this case happens to be this -
symbol or this this pound sign this
hashtag and that's only what we do if we
if we don't have a snake so if we've
crashed but if we hadn't crashed
then we pass ID and why do we pass ID
because ID the identity functions that
means that well if we haven't crashed
and the grid needs to stay the same
we didn't do that let's just say let's
say we did this in both of the cases so
instead of doing ID we do this mapping
again then it'd be a constant crash like
we're just it's it looks like constant
we're actually just redrawing this
constant and recomputing this constant
all the time but yes so that's why we
need to pass the ID and if we didn't do
this this mapping of pound that wouldn't
be the end of the world it would just
not be obvious when we've crashed so
what we want to do is visualize like
like we did in the web right like here
when we crash we have the screen sort of
turns red like that right in here in the
terminal we want we want every position
to be replaced by a dash and that's that
right that's so these are the matrix
operations that we have we we we can
make a matrix we can set something in
the matrix we can given some state
produce a function that when given a
matrix adds that snake to the matrix
similarly for the Apple and similar for
a crash similarly for a crash and then
we can take a matrix and turn it into a
representable string and then here we
have the from-from state function that
essentially first makes a matrix and the
snake adds an apple and as a crash all
in order so that we can simply just call
that from from over here in our game
loop or when we want to show okay that
lets show then we also have step but
step is super trivial similarly if we go
up here into the top like similarly to
the web right like if we go back to web
dot HTML you can sort not so web KS you
can see here in the top that we have
this mutable state where we say that the
state is equal to initial state for some
reason I chose lowercase s since
uppercase as here that makes no sense
but in the CLI here we have a variable
called state which is which starts as
the initial state from the snake and
that is the immutable state and the
reason that that's mutable is of course
that we need to listen to these key
events so I'm not gonna bother you about
how this listening to keys work but this
seems to be like the way we do it in
node when we want to listen to key
presses so we capture what's in standard
in and if we happen to press ctrl C we
need to exit the process because people
need to be able to exit the program but
if not then I'll just do to upper on it
so so we don't have to worry about lower
case
w or uppercase W and then we just look
for WASD as in the web case right and
hjkl and we look for up left down right
arrows and what we do is actually the
same thing let's let's look at this so
yes so the state is equal to the nquing
of the old state and the new moon and
then we break and this is the same thing
as we had here in the web where we said
okay and Q based on the new state this
new move and compute a new state from
that and and replace the mutable state
with this new state that's computed and
that's the way we do that and yeah yes I
guess that's pretty much it so to do
that red line we needed to read in the
base node library red line it seems that
there are other ways of doing it but
this seems to be the easiest way so yeah
it kind of seems like that's it
it seems like a lot of cold in some
sense right but if you think about it
what I would argue and what I would
argue is that what we've done is that
the snake implementation is actually
only this file it's actually only snaked
rjs like this is this is the
implementation of off snake the other
stuff regards how to display the snake
game like what graphics version or
engine you want to use your snake with
you what GUI you want to use your snake
game with so which way you want to
display snake to the user and which way
you want the user to interact with your
snake game so again like if we think
broader than game programming functional
programming is really susceptible arity
and so what I mean is when you produce
small functions you can really quickly
feel how they become very composable and
very reusable but yeah I mean but if you
actually know exactly what you're
building and you know that you're not
expecting any change and you have a
strict specification then yeah maybe you
don't need to be worried about change
but if you are worried about change like
if you're building an application
changed overtime or if you're building
something that might be shipped to
multiple platforms then approaching
something even like game programming
kind of like we've been approaching it
today I think actually makes a ton of
sense what do you think let me know in
the comments and let's discuss beyond
that if you thought this was interesting
and if you want me to decompose any
other games let me know like Tetris or
pong or whatever I mean shoot something
in the comments either way
clearly this code can be improved a lot
but hopefully you find something useful
as we go through this piece of code hey
I'm Christopher I'm the guy that you
just saw in this video I hope that you
like the video and I really hope that
you felt that you learned something if
you did like the video I would suggest
that you check out my youtube channel
the link to my youtube channel is in the
description so thank you again very much
for watching and I hope to see you in
another video either here on this
channel or over on my channel I'll see
you in the next one